[Music]
two years after a u.s
jury convicted the mexican drug kingpin
known as el chapo
his wife is the newest suspect in the
government's effort to break up the
giant sinaloa
cartel emma coronel aspero was arrested
yesterday at dulles international
airport in virginia
she faces a court hearing today accused
of being part of joaquin guzman's
massive criminal operation as catherine
harris reports
u.s officials may try to use her to
bring more of el chapo's partners
to justice emma cornell aspero
a dual u.s mexico citizen supported her
husband
throughout his brooklyn trial two years
ago now it may be her turn
the 31 year old is charged in a single
count criminal complaint
with conspiracy to distribute cocaine
methamphetamine
heroin and marijuana glizman and his
wife have been together since at least
2007
and shared twin daughters wall street
journal correspondent jose
cordoba has been reporting on el chapo
for more than a decade
she's part of the whole cartel life
she's
been in it all of her life her family's
involved with the cartel
she's cartel royalty in court documents
the justice department also accuses
coronel of helping her husband escape
from a mexican prison in 2015. as
mexico's most powerful drug lord
guzman escaped through an entry under
the shower in his cell
to a mile-long lighted tunnel with a
motorcycle on rails
documents charged that coronell worked
with guzman's sons and a witness
who is now cooperating with authorities
to organize the construction of the
underground tunnel
she was clearly exposed to
all of the things that chapo was in
control of the movement of narcotics
across the border into the united states
and obviously the flow of money back
jack reilly a retired assistant
administrator for the dea
directly tracked el chapo for about 20
years
he says cornell's cooperation could lead
to more arrests
including guzman's suspected second in
command
currently running the sinaloa cartels
operations
right now i think el mayo zimbata is the
number one
drug trafficker in the world and
certainly on our list is terms of
arresting him
and emma cornell could lead us to him
that's what my hope is there is just no
way
that they don't know each other we've
reached out to her lawyers and have not
received a statement about the charges
cornell is expected to appear in court
today via video tony
all right catherine thank you very much